كان قول وداعًا هذه المرة أمرًا صعبًا حقًا
لأنه لم يكن لدي أي فكرة حرفيًا
عندما سنلتقي ببعضنا البعض
، كان الافتقار إلى الحميمية الجسدية
هو أكبر مشكلة ،
إنه فقط الجزء الأول الأكثر
إحباطًا كما لو
أنه ليس هنا عندما أحتاج  التقينا به
عندما ذهبنا
عندما كنا ندرس اللغة الإنجليزية في
النمسا أيضًا
قبل أربع سنوات تقريبًا الآن كان من
المفترض أن أذهب لزيارتها
في عيد الميلاد في عام 2020 ، وفي ذلك الوقت
كان قد مر حوالي سبعة أشهر منذ
أن رأينا بعضنا البعض
و  قبل أسبوع من موعد رحلتي التي كان من المفترض
أن تغادر
فيها المملكة المتحدة ، أعلنوا أنهم لا
يسمحون للزوار الأجانب ،
كنت آخر مرة في الولايات المتحدة في يناير 2020
، وذلك عندما انخرطنا في ذلك قبل أن
أعود بالطائرة ، لقد ناقشنا بالفعل نوعًا
ما سنستقبله  طريق تأشيرة الخطيب
لم يكن حتى
صيف 2020 ، هل أدركنا أننا
لا نعرف كم من الوقت سيستمر
هذا لأن هذا أمر خطير حقًا
[موسيقى]
انظر ما أريد فعله هو ترك
وظيفتي  ر  يا أمريكا اترك عائلتي
أترك أصدقائي وهكذا
أممم وهذا صعب بما فيه الكفاية في
الأوقات العادية ولكن يكون الأمر أكثر صعوبة
عندما لا يكون لديك دليل عندما
يحدث الوقت هو مشكلة مالية هي
مشكلة ليس من الممكن الطيران
عبر محيط عبر قارة
عبر مناطق زمنية متعددة ،
فقط قم بزيارة سريعة تعلم أن الحياة
لا تسير بهذه الطريقة
، كان من الجيد أن تكون جزءًا من
مجموعة من الأشخاص الذين
يمرون بنفس الشيء الفظيع
، من الصعب الالتزام بهذا الالتزام
وتشعر بأي شيء أكثر من مجرد وجود
هامستر على عجلة ، فأنت تعتقد
أنك تمضي قدمًا ولكنك لا تزال
في مكانك ولا يمكنك في الواقع التخطيط
لأي شيء ، يبدو أن
تضحية
العائلات الدولية أمر
مقبول لدى الحكومة